au sac citoyens années l'udc bonsoir
alors qu'est ce qu'on fait ce qu'on
demande aux citoyens d'en faire plus ce
rendement de la ville d'en faire plus
sonic on demande aux citoyens d'en faire
plus d'être responsable parce que bon la
ville leur appartient il est que
lorsqu'on marche sur les trottoirs sont
au printemps moi j'ai fait des campagnes
de sensibilisation auprès des citoyens
et depuis plusieurs années mais quand on
marche sur le trottoir qu'on voit un
gobelet de café chez steam par exemple
n'est pas arrivé l'autre seul le gobelet
il ya quelqu'un qui le bus puis qu'il
ait acheté à terre par penser que la
neige que pour le couvrir ou les petits
cadeaux des chiens ou ou les papiers et
l'obs tout le monde se disent a pas de
bon sens à la ville est sale masse est
passé lui tout seul la ville c'est la
responsabilité des citoyens c'est pour
ça qu'on met des poubelles un peu
partout dans les dents tout les coins de
rue pour que les gens les utilisent
on peut pas toujours faire refaire et
refaire le il faut que les gens soient
responsabilisés et à chaque année y
disposaient à voir j'ai regardé sur le
site de la ville j'ai pas vu les
annonces encore mais ils se posaient
avoir des corvées de propreté dans l'arc
dans les ruelles dans c'est pour ça
qu'on est les projets de ruelle verte
qu'on voit certainement parler mais
c'est la responsabilité tout le monde de
se respecter et de respecter la vie le
qu'est ce que le citoyen peut en faire
plus c'est ce que la ville peut en faire
plus pour que le citoyen fasse plus
faciliter la distribution de sacs machin
etc
oui mais moi j'y crois juste à moitié je
pense que les corvées citoyenne c'est
souvent les mêmes personnes et c'est
celle organisée je choisir le week end
faut le faire c'est le fun j'y participe
souvent mais richard bergeron raison là
un sac devant chez toi je les applique
facto au sac et puis si deux trois
personnes qui faisaient la même chose
que toi ça va beaucoup changer quelques
remarques premièrement je trouve ça il
ya les choix des citoyens plus
consciencieux qu'avant les propriétaires
de chiens choses et de ce qu'ils font
sur le mont royal ya déjà vingt et un de
gaza font sonné c'était un slalom entre
les crottes de chine et maintenant ce
n'est plus le cas c'est impeccable donc
les bras je ne veux pas marcher dans un
parc au prêteur tu peux pas marcher pas
à moins d'avoir des bonnes spéciales et
puis de les créer père normand la maison
mais c'est ça change et des
propriétaires de chiens bravo par contre
montréal sera toujours une ville sale
pour plus raison montréal c'est une
vieille d'abord dans les quartiers où
tap plusieurs adresses qui donne sur le
trottoir c'est impossible de savoir d'où
vient la saleté casse est un bon galop
face aux trottoirs la saleté devant le
bungalow vient souvent de cette maison
là mais ça peut venir de n'importe quel
des adresses devant un immeuble deuxième
chose c'est une ville où les escaliers
sont directes sur la rue ya pas de local
à ordures à paris à barcelone etc les
escaliers donne à l'intérieur de
l'immeuble ayant un look alors ayez un
concert nous on se donne dix règles d'or
donc c est violet beaucoup beaucoup
d'étudiants alors toutes sortes de
choses qui font que la vie des halles ok
mais est ce que là on a parlé du citoyen
vous êtes le p vous avez raison c'est
peut-être toujours les mêmes et tant
mieux si on a davantage qui fondent et
qui vont ramasser des déchets un peu
partout dans les rues elle aussi mais
est ce que la ville les arrondissements
doivent en faire plus à mi-août ils ont
tel le budget pour en faire plus mais le
budget à il devrait la voir on devrait
avoir des brigades propres été faites
par des employés de la ville où des
étudiants durant l'été sur les grandes
rues commerciales mais la responsabilité
d arrondissement c'est aussi de mettre
des poubelles au coin des rues car le
poids de poubelle après trois coins de
rue mais ton papier notamment et le tu
te laisses tomber ton kleenex ou cité
masque aussi et ça c'est un problème moi
quand j'étais dans mon arrondissement on
a on avait des demandes de citoyens
disent ah ben si vous voulez pas qu'on
jette nos déchets donnez nous des
poubelles et c'est là qu'on a fait des
poubelles de rue recyclables c est ce qu
on devrait en avoir davantage du
mobilier urbain pour permettre aux gens
de pouvoir le faire et ne pas leur
donner d'excusés de dhiba y en avait pas
d'endroit pour les jeter le que ce que
le les arrondissements devront faire
plus
oui oui notamment sur tous les coins de
rue elle dans les quartiers centraux les
gens vont porter leurs sacs à tout
moment on a installé comme ça commençait
sur le plateau des groupes bac pour que
les gens me mettent leur leur poubelle
quand c'est entre les jours de passage
désormais directement dans le bac mais
s'ébattent l'on sait on se l'est fait
voler à un rythme et sarah est donc de
trouver une solution où on peut
accueillir le bac parce que la personne
qui habite dans une
notre karaté jour des poubelles il va
pas garder sacs de poubelles toute la
semaine jean miller surtout c'est un
étudiant ils veulent sortir devant sa
maison quand même à l'avant sortie
tenant sa maison quelques regardez c'est
une canette de da il va se battre la
pression d'écureuil bahia dis donc il
faut et ça va être ça la pression
quelqu'un il ya déjà les saxons à vue
mais moi aussi je veux rajouter un sac
parce que ça doit être le jour des
poubelles parce qu'il y aurait à coup
sûr de lui alors il ya toutes sortes de
défis cumulatif alors faut couper ça
mais pour couper ça il faut des bacs au
coin des rues réel l'eau suffisamment
lourd et fils est profondément ou
quelque chose comme ça oui c'est bien
pour le monde municipal aujourd'hui
c'est intéressant parce que le maire
marchand a gagné une manche importante
contre le gouvernement du québec qui
jonglait avec lui imposer des conditions
avant de lui donner un décret pour faire
son fameux tramo et tellement il y aura
d'autres conditions on écoute un petit
extrait du maire marchand qui m'a donné
une entrevue tôt leurs plans v et
monsieur bonnardel le dit lui-même et 30
personnes
bien si vous leur demandez c'est quoi
l'acceptabilité sociale des personnes
qui vont lui donner la même définition
alors il ya des gens que mon dos a
préféré qu'on va faire un référendum et
des gens qui m'ont dit oui mais c'est un
référendum se racontent les deux tiers
parce que c'est un projet important
l'osec monde estime 51% sont peu pâli
vraiment de l'avant on n'en finit plus
alors il a refusé les conditions cette
obligation de tenir un référendum sur le
projet de sur son projet de tramway à
nice victoire du monde municipal qui a
son décret il a son décret pris la
liberté de gérer ce projet là oui et moi
ce qui m'inquiétait là dedans c'est de
voir l'impact et politiques entre le
provincial et le municipal tout a sauté
quand on a parlé de partager la rue
divise et changer un peu les voies la
circulation les véhicules et celles au
québec a dit non non non ça n'a pas de
bon sens mais ça les ménages mal c'est
une responsabilité du monde municipal et
je suis contente que dans la même
semaine où on en a parlé que suzan le
roy la présidente ancienne présidente de
l'union des municipalités est choisie
comme candidate à l'ue a pour la cac
donc j'espère qu'elle sera là pour tenez
le phare sur les responsabilités des
deux paliers parce que là je pense que
complètement eu un mélange de pouvoir
parce que je comprends que le municipal
c'est un palier qui est intéressante
parce qu'on travaille au quotidien sur
des projets concrets sur le terrain avec
les gens qu'on voit des résultats
rapidement au provincial on fait des
lois en fait des gros projets mais on
voit le résultat tout de suite et je
pense que il ya certains députés qui ont
tiré peut-être voulu se mêler de
l'aménagement parce que c'est sûr mais
elle est pas mal mais pas mal trop sa
serai pas ci fais pas ça
luc
victoire pour le monde municipal selon
vous
énorme énorme et d'ailleurs bravo à
monsieur bruno marchand bien sûr que
fait face à un barrage de quatre
ministres et bravo à normal monsieur
legault bravo parce que reculer quand
son parti s'était avancé dans un
contexte particulier où les
conservateurs les menaces dans six
comtés au tour de québec où les
conservateurs font des réunions des
assemblées publiques ce précisément sur
ce projet là et de reculer en disant non
finalement on va aller avec le projet de
tramway parce que si bien pour le bien
public parce que c'est ce qu'il faut
faire et aussi parce que le monde
municipal s'est mobilisée mais ça
prenait aussi du courage alors bravo à
ces deux grands politiques parce que le
tramway à québec divise beaucoup annie
là il nous reste une minute le tramway
divise il ya en fait la majorité des
gens se disent contre ce projet là ont
l'impression qu'ils pourront moins bien
circulé mais c'est parce que il est
logique que le deal le siècle viennent
déposer en disant il faut moins de
voitures il faut tout calculer en oeuvre
un projet qui électrique qui va
permettre aux gens de circuler du
actuellement en ville de pau est obligé
de prendre la voiture on a des projets
on est en 2022 il faut aller vers
l'électrique on n'arrête pas d'en parler
ce projet le est là mais je reviendrai
toujours sur ce qu'on dit lorsqu'on
parle de circulation sur tout transport
c'est toujours un projet que ce soit
montréal que ce soit au québec c'est un
projet qui dérange peu importe qu'on
avance on recule on a vu le même exemple
à québec aulas montréal sur le métro sur
leur haine mais on l'a qu'il est encore
une fois donc ça ne l'est pas encore
prononcé le mourre m mais elle joue est
belle et je les fais du m'excuse mais
non on va reparler notre foi luxe et à
quel point ce sujet là me passionne
merci annie et l'udc à très bientôt au
revoir bonne se revoir bientôt